what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python and pandas tutorial video
in this video we're gonna be talking
about is function mapping so the idea of
this is you know with pandas get a lot
of really great built-in operations that
we can do um but we might come to a
point where we find that there's not
either either either isn't a built-in
operation or we don't know it with pins
and so this is where function mapping
comes into play and function mapping
still works pretty well with pandas so
that's what I'm gonna be showing you
guys today so the first thing I want to
do is go ahead and just delete
everything after the definition of DF
I'm just really no point to have the
rest of this stuff here so but delete
that I'll make some more space in our
edit code so now it's defined just a
simple function this is gonna be a
stupid simple function just to show you
guys that first of all it will be row by
row it will still iterate through the
row or row by row rather and trying to
figure out how to say this it basically
will work as if like you would basically
just build the function as if you were
building it or as if it was a function
built into pandas so let me just show
you guys an example so let's say define
function and then this function is all
just gonna have some data that's passed
through it so now we're gonna say x
equals and we got import random let's
just import random here in for random so
X is equal gonna equal random not Rand
range it's gonna be a random range 0 to
5 and then we're gonna just say return
return data times X Wow there we go 2
times X and so what we're gonna do is
we're going to pass a single column
through here and the the data parameter
is gonna be that whole column we're just
gonna use it we're gonna pass through
that pandas column and then X is equal a
random 0 to 5 and what you'll find is
that it for every row it's a random 0 to
5 multiple
okay so this is how we know it's
iterating through all the rows and
instead of data we could pass through
all of the columns or three columns you
can you could put data data to data 3
and or column 1 column 2 column 3
whatever you want to call the parameters
and you can perform functions on those
parameters so for now we'll just do one
column one parameter and it's just gonna
be a random range just to kind of prove
to you that it's really is iterating and
doing random things per row and so
anyway we'll see that in a second so now
we're gonna say DF and then we're gonna
say multiple because it's a multiple do
you have got multiple equals and then we
say map and then this parts a little
tricky but it's not too fancy now we're
going to say that the function that we
want to map and that's gonna be a
machine and then instead of putting in
you know more parentheses here for the
parameters instead what we do is we say
function comma and then we put the
parameters in and this one only has one
parameter so we're just gonna put that
one parameter but that parameter is DF
close now what we do is print D F dot
head
save and run it and now we can see
here's our multiple column right here
and you can see here that we you know
one of them looks like it multiplied it
by two
the next one it was zero next one is
probably three or four and then in the
next one the same thing again and then
it's zero so as you can see already just
with these few we definitely had
different ones so it's definitely
contingent by row and then it does the
entire function itself by row so really
quite simple to make your own function
so obviously you could do all kinds of
things yourself now with this and you
can also pass through things like you
could say you can reference previous
data points and all that with with going
through function mapping so there's this
pretty much opens the door for anything
that is not
in pandas yet you want to kind of use
the efficiency of pandas because this is
gonna in rate through kind of like in
generator form instead of a typical four
loop that you might write so it's still
gonna be pretty efficient it may not be
the most efficient code since you know
what you're writing in here might not be
it very efficient but you'll still be
able to utilize pandas and then once
you're done it's still in the pandas
dataframe and you can still do
everything else that you've always done
in pandas so that's just like a quick
example of what you need to do to map a
function so you can kind of keep working
with pandas it's just in case pandas
that have an operation that you really
need you can write it and then map it so
anyways that's it with this video if you
guys have any questions or comments
leave them below as always thanks for
watching